you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news coming up on today's
programme
a warning from the president of palau
that his and other nations are at real
risk of disappearing as a group of small
island states prepare a legal case
against the world's biggest polluters
we should not
ever
live in a world
where
we would have to go to textbooks or
history books to learn about these
islands and those cultures and those
people because they vanished because
of climate change
[Music]
new technology that helps the shipping
industry use less fuel and reduce
emissions by keeping vessels clean
and a winter heat wave flames wildfires
in california forcing dozens to flee
their homes
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and challenge those coming up with the
solutions
the president of palau is warning that
small island nations such as his are at
real risk of vanishing
rising sea levels and increasingly
frequent extreme weather events are
already having a devastating effect on
his small country and that's why he and
other leaders of small island states on
the front line of the climate crisis are
preparing a legal case against the
world's biggest polluters
palau is an archipelago of over 340
coral and volcanic islands of which only
10 are inhabited surrounded by a single
barrier reef
as a low-lying island nation it's on the
front line of the effects of climate
change
low-lying small islands in the pacific
are disproportionately at risk of losing
land as sea levels are set to rise by an
expected 26 to 82 centimeters by the
late 21st century according to data from
the un
now that's despite the fact that pacific
small island nation states combined are
responsible for a mere
0.93 per cent of global emissions
well earlier i spoke to president
suringel whips junior who told me how
the climate crisis is directly affecting
people's lives in palau
probably our biggest challenge
is that
before we didn't experience
storms
uh frequency of storms in the past year
we've had typhoons monsoons taken out
roads
destroyed homes and uh being where we
were located close to the equator we
weren't in what we call the typhoon belt
so
that's a direct uh result of
the change in climate
the other things that we see is uh the
rising sea levels so we have um in the
high tides now homes being flooded
um tarou's patches or we call them tarou
swamps where we get our food uh also
getting inundated with seawater but it
doesn't just stop there we also have
impacts to our coral reefs
when we have droughts and severe
drought events we've lost that lost reef
habitats to core bleaching
we also see a reduced reduction in in
fish stock uh because of uh the warming
seas so those are all
challenges that we face each day and
and maybe at
glasgow if you recall uh the term i used
is you might as well bomb us instead of
just having us suffer through this
uh continuous um struggle that we face
and that's why it's so important
that we all
rise up to the challenge and and really
work together
uh
to find innovative ways uh to solve the
climate crisis and the challenges that
we have were you reassured by what was
agreed at cop26 for example wealthy
countries there for example promised to
double adaptation finance for vulnerable
countries by 2025. do you feel that
progress is really being made
you know every little step counts
but you know i think we need to
encourage
our friends that said we need to start
taking bigger steps
and uh cop 26 was definitely a ray of
hope
that i think we're going in the right
direction
and uh you know i want to
thank france uh for being the first
country this year to
to have the one ocean um the conferences
summit in in france and i think what we
want to build on is those commitments
that were made we need to increase the
work whether it's in marine pollution
and in protecting our seas iuu and and
also
uh just
uh sustainably managing our our oceans
and really producing a sustainable blue
economy those are really the initiatives
that we need to work on together
and and and our our larger friends
uh that are making a bigger impact on
climate change need to step it up
and also contribute to the climate
mitigation and climate adaptation and uh
uh we're we're uh
we would like to see more and i think
that's why it's important that we have
these conferences and continue to push
the momentum forward because if we don't
as my friends uh from the marshall
islands and they had had me uh represent
them at the high level
uh ambition high ambition panel at
glasgow
said you know if we don't
turn this around at this conference
we're going under
and why should any country or any island
disappear
because
we didn't make the choices the hard
choices you've joined the commission of
small island states cosis on climate
change and international law to bring a
case uh to the un uh international
tribunal for the law of the sea so tell
us what you're trying to achieve with
that action and why you feel it's
necessary to take it as small islands
we see the change happening
we we suffer it every day
so really the intent is to raise that
awareness and
to make people understand that the
choices that you make
every day impact the lives of people
around the world and especially small
island states so make the right choices
you know uh
bringing that action is to encourage
people to change
to make those commitments and
and and to make the right decisions
um
so
hopefully by saying
the large polluters pay
they will take responsibility
you don't have to pay you don't have to
pay if you make if you make those
changes
but uh we need them to make those
commitments and stick to them and act
more aggressively
is it hard to feel listened to when
you're such a small nation just 18 000
people
yes
uh we're small
and it's hard to find us on the map
and uh and i think sometimes that that's
why we're we're we're forgotten
but you know one of the things that um
uh that's so important by these these
conferences and and these events it's
allowed us to raise that awareness raise
that voice
and uh you know we appreciate uh sky
news taking the time to reach out to us
and give us the opportunity to share the
challenges that we have on our small
islands
and so that the world knows that there's
we should not ever
live in a world
where
we would have to go to textbooks or
history books to learn about these
islands and those cultures and those
people because they vanished because
of climate change
uh we don't want to ever see that
and and and i believe that this
generation
of
of the of the uh in the world can make a
difference and it really requires all of
us working together
now for some of the day's other climate
news and a wildfire found by gusty winds
has erupted in hills on the southern
california coast and is burning near
homes the city of laguna beach ordered
an immediate evacuation for residents
and closed the pacific coast highway in
both directions
drax power has pleaded not guilty to
allegations that wood dust from its
biomass pellets pose the risk to
employees health safety and welfare at
work it's also charged with failing to
make a suitable risk assessment before
allowing employees to work with
potentially hazardous substances at the
biomass power station in selby which is
the largest of its kind in the uk
the trial was today scheduled for june
2023
there are concerns that northern
ireland's first legally binding climate
act might not be passed before the
devolved institutions at stormont are
dissolved next month following the
resignation of its first minister
the amended bill will see the
introduction of a 2050 net zero target
for northern ireland along with an
independent climate change
commissioner's office
australian energy giant agl has said it
will close two of its biggest coal-fired
plants several years earlier than
planned in an effort to take a leading
role in australia's energy transition
agl's chief executive said the
acceleration would cut its emissions by
18 to 27
during the
2025-2045 period compared with 2019
levels however climate groups have
dismissed the amended schedule saying
it's a token effort
seventy percent of households in somalia
do not have enough food to eat as the
country continues to experience its
worst drought in a decade save the
children says millions are going hungry
and being forced from their homes in
search of food and water the un has
warned east africa is the region most at
risk from near-term climate impacts with
three-quarters of all displacement in
somalia in 2021 attributed to flooding
or drought
the duke of cambridge has told children
you are the future while planting carbon
capturing mangrove saplings in the
united arab emirates
climate change conscious prince william
has been learning about efforts to
safeguard wetlands with the son of abu
dhabi's crown prince sheikh khalid
now the world's shipping industry is
responsible for hundreds of millions of
tons of carbon dioxide emissions every
year so just like most industries the
race is on to find ways to clean up well
one company in coventry has found a way
to help ships use less fuel and reduce
emissions by keeping them free of cross
stations madeleine ratcliff explains
[Music]
how do you reduce the amount of fuel you
need to run boats saving money and
reducing carbon emissions at the same
time
well it can be as simple as getting rid
of the barnacles on the boat
this buildup of weed and shells slows
boats down and makes them less efficient
so they burn more fuel and release more
carbon dioxide but one company might
have the answer
quite simply
the ultrasonic sound wave when it leaves
the vessel
creates tiny bubbles a tiny agitation
and when those bubbles very carefully
and slowly implode it destroys single
cell organisms that's the food source
for the weed for the barnacles for the
mussels there's nothing to eat there's
nothing will grow
this all matters because the global
shipping industry is so polluting it
produces about 940 million tons of co2 a
year that's about 2.5 of global
emissions so even a small reduction in
the amount of fuel burned can make a big
difference
if you imagine a container ship
if it's got
no fouling it would be the equivalent of
switching tens of thousands of people
from their diesel car
to an electric car that is the
difference it is making
andrea is investigating how to make
ships more efficient crucial he says to
cope with increasing consumer demand in
a sustainable way
we want ships to be
delivering our items at the same rate
without making larger ships the only
alternative is at the same speed or
faster and that means that having fuel
efficient ships is critical
in general the less algae or barnacles
you have on a hull
the better the fuel consumption will be
in the fight against global warming and
reducing carbon emissions it's often the
little things that make a big difference
something as small even as keeping your
boat clean
madeleine ratcliffe sky news in
southampton
to stay with us coming up i'll be joined
by the director and founder of uplift
tessa khan and dan caesar chief
executive of the fully charged show and
we'll be asking if small island nations
are being heard as they fight for more
aggressive action to cut emissions by
the world's largest polluters and could
insulation be the solution to the energy
crisis all that to come
[Applause]
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show on sky news and we're
getting straight to discussing the
climate issues of the day now with tessa
khan from uplift uk and dan caesar of
the fully charged channel so very good
evening to both of you nice to see you
both
so first of all climate change and its
devastating effects are already here
that's the clear message that we heard
today from the president of palau a
string of pristine islands in the south
pacific
palau is home to around 18 000 people so
how can countries on the front line of
the climate crisis often tiny have a
voice in the global debate and tessa one
way that the president of palau was
telling me that he was trying to have
his voice heard was by taking legal
action joining a group of small island
states and taking a case to a u.n
tribunal how unusual is a case like that
and what might it be able to achieve
well anna these sorts of cases basically
people turning to courts to try to find
new ways to get governments to speed up
the pace and scale at which they're
reducing
carbon emissions that in itself isn't
unusual at the national level what's
unusual here is that palau and these
other pacific island states who are
facing such an imminent and massive
threat you know to their very existence
that they're collectively acting as a
set of governments to really clarify the
obligations of other countries and you
know principally richer countries with
higher historical responsibility for
climate change like the uk which is in
the top 10 countries in the world in
terms of its historical contribution to
carbon emissions you know they're
they're trying to clarify exactly what
the legal obligations are under
international law
for those countries in terms of having
to reduce emissions and support
countries like palau that are really at
the front lines of climate change of the
climate crisis despite having done so
little to contribute to it
and you can certainly understand why
they would do that given that we are
effectively still traveling in the wrong
direction in terms of reducing emissions
at the pace that we need to to stay
within a safe climate that critical 1.5
degree threshold that's especially
important for small islands and you've
got governments like the uk at the
moment considering opening up new oil
and gas fields you know at a time when
the world's energy and climate experts
couldn't be clearer that that is
incompatible with a livable climate so i
think that's that's a whole topic that
we've
talked about a few times this week and
i'm sure we'll come back to you again
another time at tessa but but dan these
these small island estates are the ones
who are bearing the brunt of climate
change at the moment and yet in the case
of palau the president was very clear as
saying i know that most people couldn't
even find it on a map so what what does
that mean for public awareness do you
think do you think that people here will
listen to those pleas or do they think
well i haven't heard of palau in some
cases what do you think how much
resonance can his message have
well my heart went out to him i was
listening to that very kind of moving
clip and unfortunately we lack empathy
as a species we know we know that um and
it's very much a case of out of sight
out of mind with these things i mean i
think that um in world war ii there was
um twinning of cities and i think i
wonder if you know places like palau
should be twinned with places like
portsmouth and they should have like
digital communication so people can see
on the ground here in the uk what's
going on elsewhere otherwise it's just
too remote it's just too big to tackle
these people going through things right
now and we need to kind of raise
awareness of that
and tessa how important is it to get
public opinion on board elsewhere in the
world and can legal action make a
difference in that
well i think you know we should be clear
that even though the uk isn't quite as
vulnerable as a country like palau the
uk is certainly
not immune to the impacts of the climate
crisis there are already tens of
thousands of people and businesses whose
you know people whose homes have been
destroyed by flooding who have had to
relocate in recent years as rainfall
becomes more intense and more frequent
in some parts of the country so i don't
think we need to look elsewhere to
really appreciate what the climate
crisis means for all of us um but legal
action like the one that the government
of palau is is pursuing is certainly a
way i think to really clearly tell a
story about the fact that governments
have been making promises for decades
now
at the international level under these
u.n climate agreements and so on to take
action on climate change and those
promises have for the most part gone
fulfilled and to support vulnerable
countries like palau to adapt to and
cope with the impacts of climate change
so i think it's really important that
people understand that this isn't you
know something new this is something
that governments have been promising and
failing to address now for many years
dan quickly want to bring you in just
just the thought that do you think that
ultimately people are only really going
to take action when their own basement's
being flooded rather than seeing
somebody from a far
far away land talking about their issues
i hope not but the cynic in me says that
that could be the case i think we just
need you know platforms like sky to
raise the issue more and more um people
have got to kind of realize that every
action in this part of the world has
effects elsewhere and you know
as you just heard things are happening
here now as well so i really hope people
start to wake up to this and get the
message okay let's move on to our next
topic shall we because the uk's uh
climate change committee is the
government's official advisory body on
climate policy so comments by its chief
chris stark might get some traction now
he said in an interview that the
government's policy on home insulation
is very poor and he says it's insulation
as well as renewable power which is
holding the key to solving the current
energy crisis and dan criticism of the
government's policy then on insulation
and do you agree then with chris stark
that
it's a way out of the current energy
crisis good for people's bills good for
the planet
100 i think chris is actually quite
moderate in his criticism of the
government on this you know they have
consistently failed
on insulation uh you don't necessarily
need to look at an energy form
certificate of your house to know if it
is cold or drafty there's much more that
you can do
but the government needs to step up to
the plate on uh insulation what's quite
often conflated is electricity and heat
and heating in hot water is
the larger portion of your uh your bill
and if you're
you know burning fossil fuels in your
house the gas boiler or something uh
similar you know it's absolutely galling
to see that heat leave through doors
floors uh windows and chimneys and you
know you can
get your house insulated but even before
that i would strongly suggest working
out all the weather weaknesses the weak
points are in your house and just
employing draft exclusion for example
well yes some really good tips and tests
the thing is that people might even be
aware that if they improve their
insulation they can save a bit of money
but often it
involves an upfront cost doesn't it and
people are facing a squeeze on their
wallets already
yeah that's exactly right i mean the
cost of our current dependency on both
gas to heat our homes the failure of the
uk government especially when you
compare it to how quickly
other european governments for example
have managed to insulate and make homes
more
more energy efficient you know it's
really clear that this is a political
choice that the government has made not
to prioritize not just the climate cost
of continuing to
burn fossil fuels to heat our homes but
also the costs as you say you know to
people's bills which are being driven by
our dependency on gas and to people's
health you know and the quality of life
that people are really going to have to
compromise as they try and reduce and
conserve their energy use just so that
they don't get stuck with these
completely you know unimaginably
difficult
energy bills at the end of the month so
you know the costs of doing this have
not the cost of failing to really
take the way in which the uk's housing
stock is dependent on fossil fuels and
ultimately not consistent with what
people need to lead a comfortable life
is incredibly high yeah and the
government obviously would talk about
all its um energy that it's putting into
renewables at the moment it would point
out that it's a leader in in wind power
for example and that it would say it's
got plans for trying to make sure that
our our homes are more energy efficient
as well
dan practically people often don't know
where to start do they when they're um
looking to insulate their home or do
other energy efficient measures have you
got any particular tips that people
should try out so certainly draft
exclusion would be a key thing but there
are other things you can do you know
short shower is much better than a deep
bath in terms of the amount of energy
you use to heat up that water things
like aerated shower heads are relatively
cheap and easy to install uh smart
thermostats which means you don't have
to have your heating on in every room
you can have it in the rooms where you
need it and have clever things uh to to
make sure you're being as energy
efficient as possible and to be honest
this problem is not going away in fact
i'd urge people to spend the spring and
summer when things get a bit warmer
warmer to start planning for autumn
and winter the the gas
cost of gas is is going to potentially
get worse we've heard that
ultimately boiler replacements will get
cheaper things like air source heat
pumps have a huge role to play and there
are companies working really hard to get
the cost of those uh down to a
comparable level but ultimately there
are things you can do that that are that
are cheaper um and yeah i'd suggest you
know let's get ready for next winter
okay so some good tips there well tessa
khan and dan caesar very interesting to
get your views and your advice thanks
very much indeed
so that's it from me for today but
tomorrow i'll be joined by climate
activist laura young and michael jacobs
professor of political economy at the
university of sheffield but that's it
for now thanks for watching see you next
time
[Music]